the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so so today and next time we're going to
talk about psychopathology people whose
minds brain and behavior are a typical
more often than not but we'll talk about
this in a moment these people face
struggles difficulties and a huge goal
is to try to help such individuals so
we'll talk a little bit about the
history of ideas in psychiatry and
psychopathology a little bit about the
ideas of diagnosis and labels and a
little and I'll show you a little film a
patient with schizophrenia but there's
an intuition in some places and some
lives are led that psychopathology is
rare but and so I'm going to lose you
know here's a list of not all
psychiatric diagnoses but some of them
schizophrenia bipolar disorder
depression substance abuse drugs and
alcohol anxiety panic disorder phobia
developmental ones like autism ADHD and
dyslexia obsessive compulsive disorder
tomorrow I'm reviewing a lot of research
grants for anorexia and bulimia so if we
take this list that you just saw and
heard and asked how many of us in this
room know somebody that we care about
could be yourself could be a family
member could be a friend know somebody
who's touched by one of these diagnosis
if you're willing to put up your hand
whose touch and look around the room
write an incredible number of people are
touched by this and so it's a terribly
important topic to understand and to
help individuals and families who are
struggling with these things and in fact
it's estimated that it will talk about
these labels exactly that about half of
all individuals at some moment in their
life will qualify men or women at least
for a brief period of meeting some
psychiatric disorder it can be rare and
devastating like schizophrenia 1% of the
population worldwide but typically
devastating in its consequences it can
be potentially milder like depression
which ranges from very severe to
somewhat
moderate and interestingly occurs
considerably more often in women than
men and we'll talk about that next time
there was a recent survey done a public
health survey 5,000 young adults half of
them in college like you have them out
of college they survey them and talk
with them and about half qualified to
have some sort of psychiatric disorder
disorder within the last year whether
they were in or out of college didn't
make a difference in this in a study but
fewer than 1/4 of those who met some
criteria went and sought help so how you
know through recent history have people
thought about people who behaved
differently who are so depressed they
can't go to bed who hear hallucinations
who behave in agitated ways and bipolar
disorder and you know it's as much a
history story and a story of culture and
tolerance and intolerance as it is
anything else and so you know unusual or
mad behavior behavior is very disturbing
and atypical now there's debates about
all of this and so for example some
people have argued that everything that
we call psychiatric disorders is nothing
but the labels we give to behaviors that
we find uncomfortable or unproductive ok
it's nothing but that is just variation
some people are taller and shorter
some people like vanilla or chocolate
ice cream and some people do or do not
have bipolar disorder
all right so isn't it's a label that's
given for just variation in human
ability and we'll talk about that or
human performance and and there's many
consequences of that others think
there's a humanitarian need to
understand the disorders to help people
so as you think about these two sort of
perspectives you can think that when
people behaved very unusually I'll show
you a picture of this that we think some
time ago that people would literally
treffen ate that is make a hole in the
skull of individuals to attempt to let
out the demons that was the
interpretation at the time there's a
thought that the witch hunts in the 16th
and 17th centuries the Salem trials in
the United States may have involved
patients with things like Huntington's
or Tourette's people didn't know how to
interpret unusual
behavior and so you know label it as
possession or label it is witchcraft or
something like that
insanity began to be understood as some
sort of a disease but without any
approach to treating it or helping
individuals basically the process was to
segregate individuals away and you would
have very large you know pretty scary
institutions with people literally
chained and living in filthy conditions
there was nobody to care or protect for
them in a London Zoo you could go pay a
penny and watch the humans and the cages
be and it wasn't they had not as many
visitors as are in London now for the
royal wedding but they had 96 thousand
in 1814 it wasn't a rare thing to go pay
your penny and look at the scary people
more recently we understand it as an
organic illness and a psychological
illness and we'll talk about all of that
but all this is a huge point that how we
understand unusual behaviors and people
is tremendously influenced by the
historical context that you're in and
we'd like to think we're making progress
on this you know I think we are but you
know a generation from now people might
look back and say how sad you know that
in 2011 people at MIT were teaching
stuff like this right because if they
were that wrong how certain are we that
we're that right so when this has to be
a little cautious about very strong
positions on these things I think here
skulls that were discovered with a
trephination
and some evidence that the person
actually survived this kind of radical
neurosurgery or but you understand at
the time with somebody behaved very very
unusually you know people had tried to
explain what's going on and tried to do
what they can
here's you know pretty monstrous looking
devices heads and boxes and things like
this where people were trying to treat
if you want to call or control
individuals having very unusual
behaviors here's a huge hospital that
thousands and thousands the name of the
hospital's bedlam and that's what led to
the word bedlam now more generally used
for sort of wildness or craziness and
point paintings like this room from from
Goya showing a madhouse and you know it
was it was because at that time don't
forget when people there was no drug
treatment no behave
treatment people were behaving in scary
ways and there was sort of put off to
the side to be out of the range of
disturbing other people now the first
step towards to treat psychiatric
diseases turns out to be a giant misstep
but it took a long time for that to be
understood as a giant misstep
this is IGAs Moniz who did something
that all of us as scientists would it be
happy to have happened to us he won the
Nobel Prize in Physiology and medicine
in 1949 or I see the pinnacle right of
scientific respect throughout the world
and he introduced what's now called
frontal lobotomies of prefrontal
lobotomies as a treatment for severe
psychiatric disorders and in the United
States Friedman and Watts picked it up
and they went around the country taking
basically ice picks going inside and
making various cuts inside the skulls
you know by 1942 there were 5,000 people
per year worldwide documented probably
more than that these were you know cases
and don't and you know we now look at it
as a terrible idea
but at a time this is all they could
imagine you know and that seemed better
than putting people in boxes or cages
was to attempt to treat it and even kind
of a nascent understanding that very
unusual behaviors went with something to
do with the brain we now understand
these frontal lobotomies or prefrontal
lobotomies surgical surgeons surgery to
sever the connections of the frontal
lobes as not treating the disorder but
simply sedating and controlling
individuals that what you know when you
made a person who is very agitated hard
to deal with hard to control hard to
reason with you gave a procedure like
this obviously they were easier to deal
with for the doctors and nurses and
family members and that seemed like
progress and we now understand that
simply making somebody behave in a
sedated controllable way is not what we
mean really by treatment but we'll come
back to this in a minute because many
individuals who get medications don't
like to take the medications some of you
may have that experience if they feel
they're dulled down in many cases not
themselves anymore
and so it's a really tricky issue at
what level some medications or you know
start to approach that same issue of
just making people behave in ways that
other people find comfortable so a nice
example of this or you're challenging
with example of this is from your book
where there's a guy named Ray he has
Tourette's syndrome so we classified
that as a neurological disorder but it
has a sort of psychiatric pieces you
know Tourette's syndrome from if you
don't know from your own life somewhere
or another you know it from movies and
TV shows love Tourette's syndrome like
law shows with courts because what do
patients with Tourette's syndrome do
they have involuntary physical tics and
part of what they have is they they
often in during those tics they curse in
pretty horrific ways okay in an
uncontrollable way so that's ideal for
television plot lines it's unbelievably
hard for the children and adults who
have it because they're often perceived
as being scary and dangerous if they're
not in a controlled state so here's a
guy named Ray who has tics every few
seconds since age four imagine if you
haven't been maybe some of you gone
through this or know somebody it's very
tough on children to have that problem
tough on adults but real subject by time
he's an adult
he's a weekend drummer he loves to play
ping pong but his uh not doing too well
in terms of jobs he loses his jobs all
the time as home life is pretty
miserable he's a pretty miserable life
at working at home
he tries Haldol which is a drug that can
help with Tourette's and what happens to
him is he instantly cured of his tics
and the happiest person around if any of
you glanced up this yeah
yeah the slowness Anil slow that exactly
so he comes back with a black eye and a
broken nose and now in a controlled
voluntary way he curses at the doctor
right and he says like just trying to go
through a revolving door his timing is
so off that he injures himself right
because a drug has changed in some sense
who he is and he feels that he's not
himself anymore he he stays on the drug
for three years for three months it
starts to work over the next nine years
he has a steady job his family the
relations improve he's successfully
treated by sort of every objective
measure happiness at home with your
family you know holding a job that's
sort of too practical things but he
likes to live a life as two raised on
the weekends he likes to go off his
medication and be himself and be the
fast drummer and ping-pong player that
he enjoyed for his early life and then
he'll take the medication and be the
sober slow somewhat sedated individual
who is you know valued at the workplace
and it can work things out with his
family more easily so it's all these
kinds you know it's always this
interesting thing about how you're
changing people in order to help them
and then what's what's that line between
changing them to fit in versus helping
them so what is abnormal and we mean in
a very statistical sense here just you
know being at the tail end of
distributions you know some so some
things we value abnormal you know being
abnormal at one ended the distribution
in terms of a success in life so what's
a mental disorder it's a clinically
significant behavioral or psychological
syndrome or pattern that occurs in a
person and that is associated with
present distress or disability and with
significant increase of suffering death
pain disability important loss of
freedom so when I talk with
psychiatrists um I collaborated a lot
with them on research they emphasize
again the functional consequence you
know can you lead a happy personal life
can you lead a reasonably successful
professional life and that's almost the
most important thing beyond anything and
there's there's amazing stories that
make you think about sources of
of Madinah apparent madness or insanity
and a powerful story for Miss for me
it's the story of a Semmelweis so he
noticed as a physician in 1840s that the
rate of death of childhood childbirth
fever in a ward served by physicians was
four times as high as mothers an award
in the same hospital served by midwives
at that time practically every physician
was a male and every Midwife was a
female all right
but you were four times more likely to
die that's a big increase and as death
if you were in a ward that physicians
served compared to midwives so he
wondered what that was about
and he tended to know furthermore that
the deaths tend to occur when women
serially who were in one bed next to the
other there were physical clusters of
these and so he began to think was it
you know for example the priest comes to
gives a last Rite to this person does
that psychologically just you know the
scourge the next person on and he he
also found out that that Serb didn't
seem to tell the story and then he asked
it wasn't the same doctor going from bed
to bed and the answer was yes of course
it makes sense right bed to bed doctor
the same doctors going down the line of
women and what he began to notice is
that the physicians were reluctant to
watch wash their hands now this sounds
ridiculous but this is 1840 medicine and
when he asked them why they didn't wash
their hands which we would now consider
pretty fundamental in a medical
environment right the basic response was
that it was unmanly you know like men
didn't wash your hands okay I'm a doctor
I'm a man I don't wash my hands I'll
come back to this in a couple so he
asked him to wash their hands in a
solution of chlorine and lime to deaths
fell from 12% to about 1% in 15 months
all right many lives were saved because
the physicians simply washed their hand
and did not carry infections from one
person to another down the row of
childbearing women right 1848 there's a
revolution in Austria he's fired from
his job the doctors the media you think
this would be a better world but the
doctors immediately are happy they no
longer have to wash their hands and the
death rate goes right back up Joseph
Lister in 1880 figured out formally
Lister
but Lister you know what was going on in
terms of cleanliness and sanitation
Semmelweis in Austria becomes crazy tell
us he runs around to people in the
street telling them to wash their hands
and avoid physicians and he dies in a
mental institution in 1865 and imagine
if you were walking here and sometimes
when you do walk on the street you run
into people who with psychiatric
difficulties and it can be a bit scary
right imagine somebody runs up to you
right and tells you God's sakes you
avoid physicians and please wash your
hands most of us would shrink back a
little bit it'd be an unusual slightly
scary right but is he who's the crazy
person right and he's tragically feeling
that he could Justice got tell doctors
to wash her hands he would save lives
that day and into the future
so you know more recently there's a
compelling story for checklists I don't
know if you've any of you seen this book
so in emergency room you think okay
that's 1840 but now we're modern day USA
we know what we're doing and then
doctors do and other professionals wash
their hands more recently there's a
best-seller a couple years ago about
checklists so what this is was that in
emergency rooms and you may know that
there's an unfortunately high rate of
errors in hospitals even among highly
skilled physicians in the best of
academic hospitals there's just miss
communications between doctors and
nurses changes of shifts and so on just
mistakes happen and they began to use as
an experiment a small checklist like
five items did you do the following five
things about the catheter or replacing
needles or so on and almost instantly
there was opposition from the physicians
they said we're doctors and some of this
was at Johns Hopkins which is as you
know it's a famous academic place but I
think it would apply at every hospital
where doctors now with men and women
doctors okay we don't need a checklist
yeah I went to college I went to medical
school I believe a residency I got my
specialty and my boards I don't need a
checklist you know that's for the intern
right so they really opposed it but they
got almost instantly far better results
of safety and including saving lives
almost instantly from the checklists but
the physicians still don't like it
because it seems childish so even to
this day it's a bit of a challenge to
get
professionals with pride to do certain
things that go against the grain even if
it helps people's health so again we
talked about that some people think that
mental illness is nothing but labeling
that which we find unpleasant or
difficult non-conforming or deviant on
the other hand there's two things one is
again so many hands were up I think if
you around it you know that for many
many psychiatric diagnoses it's there's
a lot of misery involved for the patient
for the family I mean it's not just a
conceptual argument and therefore many
diseases like for schizophrenia for
example and very different cultures
around the world the rates are
strikingly similar around 1% will talk
about disorders like autism and ADHD
where the numbers have gone up but it's
schizophrenia for as long as people have
roughly had a definition around the
world it's roughly 1 percent which is a
lot 1 out of a hundred for a very very
severe life-altering disease so the
challenges of diagnosis are huge because
no brain disorder for all these
neuropsychiatric disorders that affects
so many people can be spotted by a blood
test or a brain image none zero to this
day everybody's working on it for many
years and that corner maker and org or
genetic test none so everything is a
discussion between the physician and the
patient and the family everything is a
discussion like that you know you can
use your common sense and do a good job
but there's risks so here's a famous
study that psychiatrists get really mad
about I'll tell you okay and you'll hear
why in a moment so this is david
rosenhan a psychologist at Stanford and
what he did is he and his graduate
students became pseudo patients they
pretended to hear voices which is one of
the signal symptoms of schizophrenia to
hear voices telling you things they and
of course if you go to an emergency room
and say you're hearing voices telling to
you to do things you get admitted you
get a psych consult and then what they
did is once they were admitted into a
psychiatry ward they just became
themselves again okay
but now they had the label that they had
had a behavior at the check-in at the
moment of admission that looked like
schizophrenia seven of eight of these
people were diagnosed with schizophrenia
by the physicians and nurses who saw
them
and it took them anywhere from three
weeks to two months to be released and
every behavior they did like taking
notes because they were doing it for the
research paper you know they were
frequently interpreted as another sign
of their disorder like you know abnormal
writing behavior okay skits and if they
got a little bit better they would say
schizophrenia but now in remission
because you understand once you have
that perspective on somebody then every
behavior can be interpreted as you know
to a momentary abatement or if you're
sitting there scribbling something
unusual writing behavior
so one pseudo patient described that he
had a close relationship with his mother
but was rather remote from his father
during early childhood during
adolescence and beyond his father became
a close friend was relationship cooled
with his mother okay so that's you know
that happens right his president
relationship with his wife was
characteristic close and warm apart from
occasional angry exchanges friction was
minimal the children had rarely been
spanked this is what he told them this
was the truth nothing's remarkable in
the story right okay but because you're
a health professional who's now trying
to figure out why did this here person
hear voices the notes were this white 39
year old male manifests a long history
of considerable ambivalence in close
relationships which began in early
childhood a warm relationship with his
mother cools during his adolescence a
distant relationship to his father's
described as becoming very intense
affective stability is absent his
attempts to control emotionality of his
wife and children are punctuated by
angry outbursts and in the case of
children spankings
your honor I mean if this is human this
is not okay because once you have a take
on somebody you sort of look for that
you connect you keep connecting the dots
and while he says that he has several
good friends once senses considerable
ambivalence embedded in those
relationships also okay you understand
that the interpreter and you could say
but this is just the problem of
psychiatric diagnosis is all discussion
and interpretation finally they were
remitted patient resumes writing
behavior oral fixation it's a little too
good to be true but there's some stories
where other patients were skeptical one
patient said quote
you're not crazy you're a journalist or
a professor referring to the continual
toke note-taking you're checking on up
on the hospital as if to freed up
patients now this is a little bit of a
fable because this makes you know a
psychiatric disorder sound like you have
we have a better sense of reality on the
world and I don't think anybody thinks
that in a deep way but but it just shows
you how far off the health professionals
were so you can you tell the story to a
psychiatrist and they get really mad at
you that means the true story it shows
you the difficulty of diagnosis the
psychiatrist I talk would say well they
could fake any disease they wanted to go
pretty far because if you know the
medical symptoms and you go and tell
doctor those things a non psychiatric
disease you could get pretty far in
terms of treatment before they figure
out something's not there right if you
know what to say
so they just think it's nothing specific
about psychiatry but any case diagnosis
so what are the criteria for diagnostic
categories signs are with the examiner
season symptoms where the patient says
and a syndrome is a cluster of science
and symptoms every neuropsychiatric
disorder is basically a syndrome it's a
cluster of things that tend to go
together but individual patient
individual patient individual patient
shows a different picture than other
people they want diagnosis that can be
relatively reliably assessed
consistently assess some sense that
there's some ability to do this but all
of this is sort of thinking things
through and then finally all these
thoughts are organized by experts
meeting and you know hotel rooms around
the country and conferences and they
produce a book called the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual of the American
Psychiatric Association DSM for dsm-5 is
about to come out in a little bit and
they have this is the official list of
diagnoses these are the lists that all
doctors use school systems use health
insurers use you have to meet the
criteria in this book to get a diagnosis
it looks like that people like to point
out that if you pile up the original DSM
s with each version the lists get bigger
and bigger all of these lists are
debated in various ways let me give you
a sense of a couple of the ones and you
can see the ones fruit so and the
dangers of the
so psychiatrists in the Soviet Union
before the Soviet Union fell were thrown
out of the worldwide psychiatric
associations because they would
regularly diagnose protesters in the
Soviet Union as being crazy
and had to be put into mental
institutions and given antipsychotic
medications because only a crazy person
would fail to recognize the correctness
of Marxist principles in the Soviet
Union and the in correctness of all
other competing systems all right now
that's we considered to be politically
abusive in the worst sense I think some
of that is thought to go on a bit in
China still and other countries but it
was manifest in the Soviet Union so you
know that we can throw out is really bad
but it just shows you know the dominant
powers in a culture can make these
decisions about 20 years ago if you were
homosexual you had a diagnosis in this
book as a psychiatric disorder on a
lighter side people who are not always
lighter so maybe people have debated
with a video game addiction should count
as a real addiction people debate all
the time you know what is the borderline
between addictions that almost everybody
agrees in terms of alcoholism or drug
dependency count as full-scale
addictions versus other things you know
what what would it take for a person not
to leave the room ever playing video
games right to count as an addiction
there's debates now in autism spectrum
disorders they're about to eliminate the
separate listings of two to two
diagnoses one of them called Asperger's
which is sort of the milder form of
autism in general they're about to
illuminate that distinction many
patients and families with Asperger's
don't like that and also something
called here's a bad label pdd-nos
pervasive developmental disorder not
otherwise specified imagine if you have
a child with difficulty and the doctor
tells you your child has pervasive
developmental disorder not otherwise
specified that's a child basically who
has two of the three components of a
diagnosis for autism so why draw the
line there and so psychiatrists I think
reasonably saying we don't really
understand the lines we're going to call
all of
is autism spectrum disorders but you
could see these things are shifting over
time these labels move as people think
about things there and there's no
definitive evidence one way or the other
besides best attempts by people to
figure out what's going on and not
everybody agrees also I'll talk about
this next time when one DSM switched to
another for example the number of
children in Germany who qualified for
ADHD diagnoses doubled overnight because
the diagnostic criteria changed that
doesn't mean that the which is the
better one
you couldn't even begin to prove which
is a better one the original one or the
one that had admitted more children into
it so these are tough calls and you
could say well it's all kind of a little
bit arbitrary and a bit subjective and
it's true at the other hand you got to
help people so why have these labels
that there's all kinds of issues well
first allocation of resources if a
person usually needs such a diagnostic
label to get services at school to get
medical services and hospitals to have
insurers support them and that's
independent of the kind of medical
service you have right second you know
if you have a label that's somewhat
useful for that helps you know what kind
of service is needed different services
are needed for a child with ADHD versus
an adult with depression or adult with
obsessive-compulsive disorder different
things are needed a label is needed to
even begin to figure out which way to go
and then people also want understand a
little bit what can they predict about
the future course at that person a
little bit of treatment and they're fine
a lot of treatment and the monitoring
needed you know you have to do something
practical and the labels help you
organize around that with all the risks
of these labels so we're going to focus
on a little bit on schizophrenia and
I'll subscribe a little bit and then
we'll see a film so sometimes the word
schizophrenia is used as a kind of a
medically incorrect way which is like
multiple personality disorder that's not
what schizophrenias that was described
by Bueller is a splitting of mental
functions dis integration of emotions
thoughts and actions about 1 percent
worldwide another 2 to 3 have a percent
have a partial version of schizophrenia
practically for every disorder there's
patients who meet the disorder and
there's patients who come close okay and
what that exact dividing line should be
and what the value of it is is is is
constant
struggled with similar around the world
is slight tendency from birth and winter
or spring people don't know why
schizophrenia happens and makes them
think about a virus as part of the story
patients with schizophrenia are defined
as having psychosis and alteration and
thoughts perception and consciousness
the thoughts are disconnected and loose
they have unusual beliefs or delusions
often a persecution somebody else
possessing their thought they can have
abnormal experiences in terms of
auditory hallucinations mood disorders
motor alteration you'll see in a movie
with restless purposeless over activity
can have impoverished social function
for a while people thought a really
important distinction in schizophrenia
was between what they called negative
and positive symptoms so the negative
ones where they did less of what a
person typically does poverty of speech
poor attention flat effect lack of
motivation
sorry that's negative and the positive
where active things that people don't
usually do delusions hallucinations
bizarre or disorganized behaviors
biologics has been hard to show that
that's kind of a distinction that
matters and so what happens with
patients with schizophrenia um very
mysteriously the clinical onset in most
cases is late adolescence and early
adulthood and nobody understands this so
very typically it's in your 18 20 22 24
how is it that such a psychiatric
disorder waits that long and not much
longer in the vast majority of cases
what what you know biological thing is
ticking in a person that will lead to a
psychotic break with reality a huge
amount of research now is to try to look
at individuals who are in their teens
and put you know step in and stop
somebody before they have the psychotic
episode the positive symptoms are most
evident in this acute schizophrenic
episode negative symptoms per often
predominate in the long run huge
variability from one person to the other
in terms of outcome the outcome often
responds positively to antipsychotic
drugs it's estimated about quarter of
patients make a pretty strong recovery
about a quarter remain very disturbed
and about half are going back and forth
fluctuating over the years so a picture
that people will use is you know it's
premorbid functioning
and then somewhere in the late teens
early 20s some dramatically bad thing
happens and then some sort of stable
condition with occasional relapses and
and a lot has to do with the challenge
of individuals like this taking their
medications partly being organized
enough to take them partly again feeling
like the real selves aren't often is not
what the Medicaid itself is you may know
the movie A Beautiful Mind with John
Nash and it's just an example you know
how psychiatric disorders you know
challenge people of every mental caliber
so he won the 1994 Nobel Prize in
Economics and if you've seen the movie
although it's interesting if you've seen
the movie also you could go up on
YouTube and see him talking about the
movie because he they sanitized him
somewhat to make him more popular with
the movie going public
okay because they made it you know a
more charming disorder then everybody
says it was including himself but he was
he terrific aptitude for math went to
Carnegie Mellon Princeton for his PhD
famous for bargaining problem and
non-cooperative games theory came
tonight in MIT in 1951 as an instructor
and then after doing this fantastic work
that one huh no bail prize developed
acute schizophrenia so why don't we
watch the movie Tyler can we do that let
me and do this so here's a fairly
typical patient
you
yeah sir hi you know I have no idea is
any different rate of schizophrenia
people who
ah that's a yeah okay I should get you
know somebody who were deaf would they
hear voices in their schizophrenia
you know is offense that any questions I
had no idea I've never you thought about
that that that's it's rare that's
combination of the two are moderately
rare you know just numbers-wise would
that be an interesting question yeah I
don't know any other I saw another hand
or no okay so um so we know one thing
that for every practically for every
neuropsychiatric disorder there's strong
familial evidence that there's a genetic
component to the disorder and a big one
so here are four I mean this is a very
touching picture in a way these are
identical quadruplets four girls who all
grew up to have schizophrenia
not every identical twin will do that so
if one twin has schizophrenia half the
time the second twin will have
schizophrenia if it's dizygotic it's
still higher than 1% but it gets down to
15 15 percent but I think people have
rethought this because very often the
sibling or the or the twin if you look a
little bit more carefully they won't
meet the diagnostic criteria but they
often have struggles of some kind as
well the lifetime probability in a
first-degree relative is 10% versus 1%
if you one parent is 13% to parents 50%
so all this is you know lots of
suggestions there's a genetic basis
concordance rates for monozygotic twins
for identical twins is almost identical
whether the we are together or apart
again suggesting a very strong genetic
basis being adopted away from relatives
does not reduce the risk having said
that if it's not a hundred percent
concordance there's got to be something
else going on besides the simple genes
at birth right but it is higher in urban
areas areas that we think have more
stress in them people have noticed that
when oftentimes when people move
cultures for example
African communities in London were of
recent Emma grace they kind of seem to
notice a higher rate as well as if a
big cultural move can pull your risk so
and so everybody pretty much agrees that
there's what people will call a
multifactorial polygenic environmental
threshold model that is there's a lot of
different genes plus environmental
stressors that come together in some way
we don't understand so and you would
think that you know with a human genome
decoded to a large extent and so on that
we'd have some clarity on this it's been
you can debate this and certainly
identifying the genes that put you at
risk with these disorders is a hugely
important topic the progress and
identifying certain genes for any of
these psychiatric disorders has been
horrible ok f G's are identified one
year the next five studies don't
replicate it and so on so people the
Broad Institute across the street now
say for them to believe that a gene is
associated with schizophrenia they think
you have to this samples of 10,000
patients with schizophrenia in 10,000
people without it what does that mean
that means there's nothing like a
smoking gun gene right 10,000 to have
enough statistics this is a port of
difference that means many many of the
10,000 don't have that gene who have
schizophrenia right okay if it were one
gene one disorder
you don't need 10,000 people to get a
statistic you need five people so it's
been a shock to people that there's been
so slow progress given that all the
things that can decode in the genome to
find the genes that are at the heart of
psychiatric diseases and that's true for
practically all of them
so we're there's something complex about
genes environment and people that far
exceeds our understanding at the moment
at every level and so people do models
like this because it makes us feel
better and there's something probably
right about it
yeah there's a mount of stress in your
life that can come up from how you're
you know socio-economic risk health
problems family situations there's a
predisposition that's genetically based
and you know some combination of them
determines whether you manifest a
disorder or don't
so we said there's no definitive
biological marker for schizophrenia as
there is for every other psychiatric
disease there's no blood test nope
test no nothing that definitively tells
you if a person has a diagnosis but
people have been studying things that
are an average different in brains and
I'll show you some of the most
consistent findings about ventricles
about hippocampal involvement PET scans
I'll show you this I'll show you a few
examples in schizophrenia so one thing
people have noticed is that if they
compare these are identical twins and
you can see the ventricle the fluid
filled space is somewhat larger than
twin with the diagnosis than without
that's about the least specific brain
marker we could ever have the ventricle
just means that there's tissue missing
around it okay it's just this fluid
fills space there should be a bit more
tissue it's very far from any specific
biology the disorder and here's the
actual twin through their actual MRIs so
we don't think it's the size of the
ventricle that makes no sense but that's
somehow roughly correlated with over the
brain basis of the disorder is and then
people have shown and these are
relatively extreme examples post-mortem
samples here's the hippocampus and
healthy individuals here you can see
it's somewhat shrunken in patients with
a diagnosis of schizophrenia and if you
look at those pictures that are kind of
picked you could say well that's easy
you know give me the MRI and I can I'll
tell you who has it but it statistically
doesn't work that way at all there's
tremendous overlap and the size of the
campus between health people without a
diagnosis and people with schizophrenia
so it's a statistical thing people also
know the cellular organization sometimes
looks somehow better in patients with
schizophrenia
the typical people's and people with
schizophrenia again a suggestion about a
developmental history underlying this
for the risk but without any kind of
certainty when they've done studies
looking at resting scanning a metabolism
you're just laying there this is a PET
scan it's just where's the blood flowing
you can see that this is a healthy
person a lot of our blood flows as we
sit there to the frontal cortex and you
can see it's kind of diminished in
schizophrenia but again you cannot put a
patient in and say this patient has
schizophrenia because many patients will
look like many controls but the average
can look like this here's a task now of
a
memory tasks so people see in the easy
condition letters are running along and
every time there's an X they push a
button that's the easy condition here
letters are presented rapidly and every
time the current letter is identical to
the one you saw two letters ago you push
a button so this is harder mental work
harder working memory demands and then
here's what you see in one data set so
you know people as they're doing this
task they turn on a lot of frontal
cortex working memory thinking you're
used to that here's controls how much
they turn it on the front of the brain
viewed from the top
here's relatives who don't have the
diagnosis and here's patients who do
have the diagnosis these are relatives
of these patients and take a look at
that you can see they're growing so this
is this issue if it's more activation
better or worse well it all depends the
way we interpret this is for typical
person here's how much they have to push
you know the pedal to accomplish that
working memory task if you're a patient
you have to push it a lot more to do the
task and you still make more mistakes if
you are relative without a diagnosis of
schizophrenia you're somewhere in
between
and those palliative are as accurate as
controls but they perform somewhat more
slowly this is a kind of interesting
thing and practically every disorder if
you take the relatives of people with
the diagnosis they often look like they
have a kind of a milder version of that
but they may have no problems in their
lives they may be doing flourishing ly
well in every regard that you can think
of but they Harbor some of the same
genes to be a relative means two shared
genes and so that can make you know so
there's something about that happening
here or in some subset of those
individuals practically every study
that's done if you take the relatives of
people with a diagnosis there's some in
between this compared to people picked
in families without any history of that
disorder but what matters is the
boundary right I mean this this
difference doesn't matter if this person
is doing well you know this difference
is associate with something that really
makes a big difference in the person's
life
the question about auditory
hallucinations and the Deaf this is kind
of like that but this is people hearing
people but one of the things you can do
with imaging is ask what some patients
with schizophrenia have rapidly psyching
auditory hallucinations most almost as
every here and there but some have it
pretty often so you can put them in a
scanner and when they hear a voice they
push a button and you can ask when they
hear of voices or auditory cortex active
in at the level of the brain is it as if
they were really hearing a voice and
here's the auditory cortex active in the
individuals at the moment they're
experiencing the hallucination it's real
to them because somehow it's engaging
the auditory cortex that really here's
the world that's why it's so powerful
all right and it's it's somehow engaging
the very same tissue by which you really
hear the world how about treatment so
we'll talk next session we'll talk a lot
about different kinds of treatment
neuroleptics are the most common
treatment for schizophrenia they block
I'll talk a bit about this postsynaptic
dopamine receptors the drug is fully
effective within hours but maximal
clinical effect takes weeks and then
remains after you stop the effect
remains after the treatment stops a huge
problem schizophrenia our side effects
of these kinds of drugs so early on you
get you induce a bit of Parkinson's
disease in patients who never had
Parkinson's disease with these typical
drugs is atypical drugs they have their
problems I'll just focus on a typical
drug so I'll tell you why in a minute
and then later on this becomes in as
tardive dyskinesia in about 20% of
patients is a lot of patients this this
is that you're producing by the drug
abnormal and voluntary movements
smacking of lips chewing and drug
protrusion and there's some drugs that
don't do it but they have other problems
and there is evidence that behavioral
therapy can be surprisingly useful in
schizophrenia there's a you know most of
us hardcore biologists we think the
drugs got to be the deal I think there's
more evidence than you would imagine the
behavioral therapy or the combination of
the two can be very helpful for people
so you may know now you wouldn't know
this I know this okay because I'm
constantly in the fundraising business
of
researcher drug companies have almost
stopped working on developing treatments
for psychiatric diseases and they've
almost stopped because it's been so
unsuccessful the drugs that were found
were almost always by happenstance drugs
that were almost randomly tried for
various disorders or various groups and
worked none of them were rationally done
in any some biotechnology sense okay or
molecular chemistry design sense they
were all happening all of them were
happenstance applications of quasi
random drugs and then people noticed it
helped individuals and so in the last
twenty years where there was much more
rational development of drugs it's been
spectacularly hard to develop new drugs
for psychiatric disorders so most
pharmaceutical companies have basically
stopped in the last couple years they've
just given up we remain optimistic
everybody thinks they'll come back into
the picture when some academics produce
some things that look good but it turned
out to be really hard and furthermore
many of the medications that are
effective have all these side effects on
this very undesirable side effects
sometimes at the same time the fact that
these drugs effect the disorder sort of
promoted various theories so once people
notice that the antipsychotic
medications medications that diminish
the psychosis of schizophrenia act on
the dopamine system that led to the
dopamine theory of schizophrenia so they
say well if the drug is pushing down
dopamine and that's helping people be
less psychotic then maybe with the real
problem is that you know there's too
much dopamine flowing in the brain of
individuals with schizophrenia and that
got supported by studies that if you
give typical people overdoses of
amphetamine you induce something that
looks a bit in a typical person like the
paranoia schizophrenia and so let's talk
about this idea of drug action versus
disease so if you have a headache what
do you take to help yourself with the
headache ibuprofen or aspirin or
something like that does that mean the
medical problem was you didn't have
enough aspirin in your blood where you
hypo ask for anemia no right the aspirin
is doing something else to counteract
the headache or the ibuprofen right it's
not that you were short on Tylenol right
okay but it treats the problem so
if a drug treats schizophrenia by acting
on the dopamine system does that mean
dopamine was the culprit and the answer
is probably not as far it's hard to
figure out but the original assumption
that the way the drug works gives you a
direct insight into what the cause of
the disease is people have pretty much
dismissed but what drew them to it of
course is still these antipsychotics the
way they work is they block the
receptors that take dopamine and
therefore dopamine gets you know
catabolized here and is not used in
neurotransmission and furthermore in fed
Amin which produces a somewhat
schizophrenic like schizophrenia like
syndrome and some in healthy individuals
that accelerates the production of
dopamine so that seemed to favor the
story but again that's sort of not taken
very broadly now again what favor the
story was the more powerfully a drug
bound to dopamine receptors the less
drug you had to give patients I mean all
of that you could see make people think
this is the story and it may be that
dopamine is a part of the story but
everybody understands and they're just
because a drug acts on a disease does
not mean it's treating the disease in
the most direct way and now why do
patients get tardive dyskinesia why is
an inadvertent consequence of treating
schizophrenia producing a version of
Parkinson's disease it's because the
drugs are too nonspecific so we know the
ventral tegmental area in the brainstem
sends dopamine into the basal ganglia
and into the prefrontal cortex
conceptually what we understand we're
trying to achieve with schizophrenia is
something like diminishing something
about this pathway but the drug can't
just you know block this it also affects
the basal ganglia and what Parkinson's
disease is is a shortage of dopamine in
the basal ganglia in case of Parkinson's
disease it's because of death of
substantial Negril cells but you're
producing a pharmacological version of
Parkinson's disease in the effort to
treat schizophrenia not in all patients
not as severe as Parkinson's disease but
a big side effect in many patients and
there's other drugs they have their
problems there's almost no drug that's
that's
completely successful and pure in any
you know treatment sense for the patient
despite that there's been a fantastic
effect we talked about that when people
were you know behaving very oddly and
certainly schizophrenia is perhaps the
scariest set of behaviors if you have to
pick one disorder in that way then you
know once they began to have drugs that
diminished the unusual behavior people
were led out of state and government
hospitals where they had been sort of
secluded in many ways and not helped in
many ways and people view this as a
tremendous success and I think it is to
let people back into the community
interacting in a sort of more typical
way as opposed to being segregated in
areas that we're often not the best but
there was a fantastic consequence which
is now these people as you may know have
no safety net they're back in the
community and if they don't have people
who care for them or follow them you
know there are risk for themselves so
it's great to give a medication to let
somebody out everybody agrees on that
but then if you don't have a kind of a
safety net of physicians and family and
so on and persons out on their own to
stop taking the medication who's there
to help them so it's a societal
challenge on top of that so next time
I'm going to talk about treatments for
neuropsychiatric disorders but for just
one minute I'll ask you have any
questions or thoughts about this whole
topic yeah
there's a fantastic the question was why
is there such a fantastically high rate
of smoking which there is in patients
with schizophrenia bipolar you know so
people will use phrases like they're
self-medicating in some way but I don't
think there's a you know you can make up
a little bit of a story but it is very
striking I don't have I don't know a
deeper story than that there might be
but it's very striking
it made the voices go away yeah ah you
know I don't know I mean there's but
it's very there's a phenomenal high rate
of smoking among patients like that okay
thanks very much
you